[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
easy
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
good evening good evening good evening
it's so good to welcome you all back to
sf jazz please give yourselves a round
of applause for leaving the house
[Applause]
my name is nick breisowitz and i'm the
director of strategy here at the long
now foundation and every november i jump
on stage for a minute just to remind the
world that the long now foundation is a
non-profit organization and specifically
we're a non-profit that relies on the
support of members and friends like all
of you to continue our work from year to
year um i always jump on stage in
november because it's the beginning of
what we call giving season
and we actually raise a formidable
fraction of our general operating budget
every year
in the last like eight weeks of the
calendar year before
and so it's an important time of year
for us and this particular year is
especially important for us because it's
our 25th anniversary year
thank you
and as we're taking time to reflect on
all of the things that we've been able
to accomplish and set in motion in that
first quarter century we're also taking
a lot of time to think about this next
quarter century the next 25 years
between now and 2046
and we're thinking about what the world
needs from the long now foundation and
where the world needs more long-term
term thinking uh in this next 25 years
so that's a conversation and it's a
conversation that's opening up and it's
keeping me really energized and extra uh
excited about this and i want to invite
all of you to continue that conversation
tonight after this event um we're going
to be gathering together at beer garden
which is just one block away it's an
outdoor venue that they're going to keep
the kitchen open for us they're going to
serve drinks late for us
it's just it fell in octavia so if you
don't have plans afterwards and you
don't need to get back in your house
please come join us for a conversation
about so much that we can do around
long-term thinking thank you so much and
enjoy the show tonight
i can tell you uh it has been a long 22
months
welcome
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now and now i have
a beard i look like this
um
it's been like i said a long 22 months
um
i'm so glad that this is a talk that we
really get to come back with and neil
stevenson has been a a very long time
fellow traveler with long now and i i
was reading his books even before i
started with long now 25 years ago
and uh they're always some of the most
evocative ways to look at the future and
then as uh we got to know him and work
with him on on some projects um we will
talk about that a little bit later he
actually submitted some of the first
clock ideas uh on this project and he
has this kind of amazing prophetic
ability to take a piece of technology
and then push it into
the future and see
the way that's going to affect society
and in some cases a little bit too
prophetic i think um kind of dangerously
so but tonight in in in lieu of trying
to ruin this book for you we're actually
going to talk about one of those types
of technologies that is uh in part of
the of this next book we're actually
going to kind of take a look at it from
a scientific point of view that um i
think is going to be an interesting
lesson the way we look at thousands of
years in the past and thousands of years
in the future
especially around climate change so
welcome neil stevenson
[Applause]
normally when i do a reading i read from
my own book for obvious reasons
but this time i'm going to try something
different i'm going to quote from some
fascinating books written by other
people and as i do i'm going to flash
the covers up on the screen to give due
credit to the authors and so that you
can follow up if you want to read more
on your own
in 536 a.d the byzantine historian
procopius was in italy describing a year
without a summer
during the whole year the sun gave forth
its light without brightness like the
moon and it seemed extremely like the
sun in eclipse for the beams it emitted
were not clear like those it usually
makes
john of ephesus reported similar
phenomena in the eastern part of the
empire the sun darkened and stayed
covered with darkness a year and a half
although rays were visible around it for
two or three hours a day they were as if
diseased with the result that fruits did
not reach full ripeness all the wine had
the taste of reject grapes
john lydis a byzantine official posited
a physics-based explanation for the
anomaly the sun becomes dim because the
air is dense from rising moisture as
happened in the course of the recently
passed 14th indiction which is to say
535 and 536
for nearly a whole year
cassiodorus at the same time wrote how
strange it is i ask you to see the sun
but not its usual brightness to gaze on
the moon glory of the night at its full
but shorn of its natural splendor
we are all still observing a sun as blue
as the sea
we marvel at bodies that cast no shadow
at midday and at the force of strongest
heat reduced all the way to the
impotence of extreme mildness
and this is not the brief absence of an
eclipse but as one that has taken place
for nothing short of almost the whole
year we have had a winter without storms
a spring without mildness a summer
without heat
there was no way that these riders could
have known it but the events they were
describing were triggered by two or
three massive volcanic eruptions
elsewhere in the world that all happened
to occur in a span of a few years
beginning around 536.
one might have been in iceland another
somewhere in the tropics and one was
definitely at ilopongo in what's now el
salvador
ilopongo alone produced 87 cubic
kilometers of ejecta and had devastating
effects on the mayans
at the same time up in scandinavia a
culture was dying out this was a
precursor culture to what we later
called the vikings historians have
debated why this culture waned and
disappeared and there were probably a
number of reasons but it couldn't have
helped that in a part of the world that
was already famous for cold weather and
marginal agriculture they got hit with a
series of incredibly cold winters
no direct accounts survive but the
nordic cultures that arose afterwards
may have preserved some cultural memory
of the event in their stories for them
the end of the world
would come not in fire but in ice a
terrible winter called the thimble
winter or the mighty winter so here's a
passage from the edda first of all that
a winter will come called fimble winter
then snow will drift from all directions
there will then be great frosts and keen
winds the sun will do no good there will
be three of these winters together and
no summer between
another edict poem the crs's prophecy
states black become the sun's beams in
the summers that follow weather is all
treacherous the sun starts to blacken as
the sun vanishes the stars fall into the
sea where their heat raises a great
steam that covers the sky
the finnish kalivala contains the
following what wonder blocks out the
moon what fog is in the sun's way that
the moon gleams not at all and the sun
shines in it all
parenthetically i'd be remiss if i
didn't point out what's probably obvious
to all of you which is that these
legends of anomalous long winters that
change the course of human
destiny are of course fundamental to
george r r martin's song of ice and fire
aka game of thrones
doom by neil ferguson catalog several
post-volcanic winters an eruption in
peru
in 1600 was followed by severe winters
in scandinavia and a famine in russia a
1640 eruption in japan
led not only to cold summers and failed
harvests in its vicinity but droughts in
greece egypt india and other places
after the 1783 eruption of loki a
volcano in iceland benjamin franklin
wrote of a constant fog over europe and
parts of north america the mississippi
froze at new orleans and the resulting
food
shortages some historians believe helped
touch off the french revolution
1816 was called the year without a
summer because of the eruption of
tambora in indonesia it and the earlier
lockheed eruption in iceland are
basically tied for the modern record
each put about 110 million tons of
sulfates into the air
the long now foundation owns property
that's home to a number of ancient
bristlecone pine trees
researchers have been able to sample
these and use tree ring analysis to see
how the growth rate varied from year to
year as a result of changes in weather
sometimes the effects are obvious enough
that anyone can just see them by looking
at a slice of the wood but there are
also special staining techniques that
can make the changes more obvious
2036
bce was apparently marked by a large
volcanic eruption that left a clear
discontinuity in the sample on the left
the sample on the right shows a couple
of anomalous years around 1419 bce you
can identify them from the blue fringes
in the staining
here's a plot of tree ring data what's
being plotted here is the thickness of
the rings which gives you an idea of
growing conditions
year by year a higher value suggests a
better growing season a low value
suggests that the weather was bad i've
superimposed some vertical red lines
showing the dates of some of the big
eruptions mentioned in neil fergus's
book some of the big drops are
observable in years following some of
the big eruptions notably
lombok indonesia which is the the left
most one
and the one in peru
which is here
but in other cases like lucky
there's not much of a change um
so um
this is
kind of interesting
in that
you don't always see a strong one-to-one
correlation between these eruptions
these volcanic events and whether in a
particular part of the world there's a
global effect
but those effects are distributed
just because of the complexity of
atmospheric physics
here's a similar chart done better in
the lower part of the chart you're
seeing two plots a bunch of spikes drawn
in black
which are telling you the uh the amount
of volcanic aerosols in the atmosphere
so for example there's a super high
spike
right here
in the late 1200s
this
group here is probably tambora around
1816.
this one here is probably locky and so
on and so forth
so
then the blue line is showing
the
how much the temperature is thought to
have deviated from average
and again the correlations aren't always
perfectly one for one we see a big drop
after tambora
down here but there's other cases where
uh where nothing seems to happen
so um
at the other end of the 19th century
edvard munch painted this famous
masterpiece the dramatic red sky in the
background is open to interpretation of
course but
the painting was made not long after the
eruption of krakatoa which depressed
temperatures all over the world
and created spectacular sunsets like
this one for a couple of years
afterwards
in the 1960s yet another eruption in
indonesia put a plume of ejecta into the
atmosphere the australians got a plane
in the air to take samples when it
landed they noticed a deposit
on the windscreen
one of the australian scientists licked
it
and reported that it was painfully acid
a more sophisticated analysis found
that it was sulfates
sulfuric acid basically
in 1991 when mount pinatubo erupted in
the philippines it was possible to
gather a lot more scientific data beyond
the now familiar
empirical
sensations of depressed global
temperatures and brilliant sunsets this
is all quite well understood when sulfur
dioxide is injected into the
stratosphere it combines with available
water to form sulfuric acid which drifts
around in the form of a very large
number of tiny
droplets when such a droplet is struck
by light from the sun some of the light
will bounce back into space
so it never reaches the troposphere
which is where weather happens and it
can't warm up the planet
some of the light will be deflected
sideways this contributes to a general
brightening of the sky
that explains the beautiful sunsets as
well as some of the mysterious
atmospheric phenomena described by those
byzantine and scandinavian sources as
well as benjamin franklin himself
and some of the light keeps going down
and continues to warm the earth as usual
this keeps happening for a couple of
years which is how long it takes for the
sulfates to wash out of the atmosphere
then everything goes back to normal
sulfates have remarkable leverage
against global temperatures the amount
of sulfates needed to cool down the
earth by one or two degrees simply isn't
that large
it's easy to imagine engineered delivery
systems that would duplicate what
volcanoes have done many times in the
past high altitude tanker planes high
altitude balloons and big guns have all
been mentioned
this kind of thing goes under the name
solar geoengineering
it's a perfectly well-known concept
among scientists who study these things
but it doesn't get talked about much
because it's controversial
unfortunately the co2 level in the
atmosphere
keeps on rising regardless this is a
screen grab
from just a few days ago showing that
the current level is about 414
parts per million
that's up from 411 in the last year
the graph on the lower right
just happens to begin around the time i
was born
and
it shows that just during my lifetime
it's gone from below 320 parts per
million to almost 420
and if you look at the shape of that
curve not only is it going up which
means that the problem is getting worse
but it's got a little upward curve to it
indicating that the pace at which it's
getting worse is accelerating
prior to the industrial revolution this
number was in the mid 200s today it's
the highest it has been since a few
million years ago
when the world had a completely
different climate
various governments have announced plans
to cut back on carbon dioxide emissions
china for example is saying that by 2030
their emissions will level off in other
words if they do that and every other
country in the world does likewise the
co2 level will at that point become a
mere linear function of time it'll still
be going up at an impressive rate but
the rate itself won't be increasing this
plot will no longer have that slight
upward curve
it'll just be a straight ramp angling
upwards by something like 2060 or 2070
it's hoped that the world economy might
reach net zero carbon emissions this
doesn't solve the problem it'll turn
this curve into a flat horizontal line
if the co2 level in the atmosphere is
say 500 parts per million in 2070 it'll
remain at 500 until natural processes
can bring it back down again
which is expected to take on the order
of a million years
there are a lot of ways in which this is
bad but perhaps the most serious threat
that we can expect to see materialize in
coming years is that of so-called wet
bulb disasters in which temperature and
humidity both get so high is to make the
survival of humans a physical
impossibility
kim stanley robinson's ministry for the
future opens with a harrowing depiction
of one such event in india
that all sounds pretty bad and like the
kind of thing that a well-ordered
society would mount an effective
response to but we're at the end of
almost two years of a global pandemic in
which a significant fraction of people
refuse to believe in the very existence
of a disease that's killing people
all around them in the hundreds of
thousands
so from all of this it's completely
obvious that the human race is going to
have to build carbon capture
technologies on an incredibly massive
scale
if you think of this in terms of all the
coal mines that have been hollowed out
of the earth's crust all of the
petroleum deposits that have been
drained
all of the forests and peat bogs that
have been burned basically we have to
fill those back up again with stable
carbon carbon-containing compounds that
we'll have to manufacture
we'll need to do it fast
it'll be by far the largest engineering
project in the history of the world
i believe that we will do it and that a
hundred years from now this problem will
have been solved atmospheric co2 levels
will be back to where they were before
the industrial revolution
that's the good news
the bad news is that it's going to take
decades and during that time we're going
to begin seeing disastrous events such
as the one depicted in the ministry for
the future
on those rare occasions when people talk
about solar geoengineering at all it's
conventional to describe it as an idea
that's on the extreme fringe and that
deserves to be there because it seems so
dangerous
much more research is needed is the
usual conclusion
i do wonder whether it will continue to
seem all that dangerous a decade or two
down the road when climate disasters are
leading directly to mass fatalities
particularly given the fact that nature
has already performed the experiment for
us on several occasions and we know that
the sulfates naturally wash out of the
atmosphere in a couple of years
danger is always relative jumping out of
a moving car is dangerous but people
will do it anyway if the car is about to
go over a cliff
so in my book termination shock an
individual billionaire constructs a
large gun that shoots sulfur into the
stratosphere simulating what volcanoes
do
this is already a fadicam plea at the
beginning of the story and so what it's
mostly about is how people react to it
needless to say not everyone is happy
just to give some sense of scale the
amount of sulfur that this fictional gun
is capable of launching
over the course of a year's continuous
operation is only about one percent of
what mount pinatubo put into the air
explosively but in his mind it's just a
pilot project and the plan is to build
more such facilities in other parts of
the world
and uh that is the setup for a kind of
geopolitical
uh thriller that is is essentially the
story of those who uh those who are
happy about this plan and those who are
extremely unhappy
um so we're going to turn it over now
to a conversation with xander and some q
a
but um
before we do i just wanted to flash up
the earl for comanche eagle.org
how this is relevant to termination
shock won't be obvious until you get
deeper into the book
they have not endorsed my book in any
way so i'm not claiming that but i'm
endorsing them as a remarkable
organization that's doing important work
not just in preservation of raptors but
also in curating many other records and
artifacts of the comanche tribe
they don't like to call them artifacts
they say life objects
this is an older flash website but if
you skip the intro you'll be taken to
this page with it's all important donate
button on the right comancheeagle.org
so as soon as you're all done
contributing to the long now foundation
if you've got any pocket change left
this is the kind of organization where a
little would go a long way
so uh with that i think we can shut the
projector down and uh and go to the q a
mode thanks
[Music]
thank you um there's gonna be some
people walking around with cards if you
don't already have one um and uh stuart
brand has volunteered to sort them for
us and we'll be sending them up here on
stage
um
thank you i think the the um
the setup of the of a rogue billionaire
doing geoengineering is
do you how likely do you think it is
that a
a person will do it versus a government
i think that's a fun way to do the story
it's a fun way to do the story yeah i
think i have to to do some work in the
story explaining how this guy is able to
get away with it
but
having it be an individual
makes for kind of better storytelling um
realistically
i think it would be a pretty hard
caper to to pull off so
what what i kind of think is more
realistic is that at some point
especially if we start seeing these wet
bulb events or other mass casualty
disasters that some government somewhere
is going to run the numbers on this and
say
you know
uh
we don't care what anyone thinks of us
uh this is this is going to be a good
deal for our country
and so we're going to go ahead and do it
and we've had um we've had david keith
here who's been doing some of the early
kind of numbers on this as well as kelly
windsor who
in the audience years
but uh
uh
who's actually working on getting this
research really done it's interesting i
think that
you're right that at the conclusion of
all these conversations people say we
need to do more research yeah but
they're not really doing it well not
only that but a lot of times when people
do try to start research programs they
get shot down
um because even doing research uh
is viewed as being being uh beyond the
pale
yeah even when i think when david keith
spoke here we had about 20 people here
thinking uh that he was
doing that
aerosols in the atmosphere you know for
brain control and yeah and that whole
thing so it quickly goes
sideways yeah yeah they they they're
getting it and they're in a crossfire
from environmentalists on the left
and from people on the right who think
it's all associated with chemtrails
so
and how did you get going down this path
what was their impetus for for starting
down this
um i had been kind of tracking it for
for a while uh
and um you know it's kind of an
inherently interesting science fictional
topic you know the notion of volcanoes
having these these huge effects on human
destiny and particularly the uh
the
what a mystery it was to like the the
romans i mean they had no way of knowing
that a big volcano had blown up in el
salvador right right so to them there's
just something happened
yeah yeah um
so there's that uh and then i've i've
brushed up against a few people looking
at sort of cloud brightening and other
uh
space-based uh solar geo engineering
which means putting stuff at l1 between
the earth and sun
to block some of the sun's light
so it's an idea that's been in the air
for a little while
and i just kind of reached a point uh
in 2019 where i thought you know
if not now when uh i'm supposed to be a
guy who writes books about um technical
subjects and you know why why haven't i
tackled this one yet
because
it's interesting you were able to kind
of cross correlate some data from the
long now property uh these prison guns
in fact this uh this is the core of that
tree that uh that he was
referencing in that slide it's a
thousand years of bristlecone um right
there and um you know when we're
designing the clock to last for 10 000
years one of the things the clock does
it synchronizes itself to solar noon on
a sunny day and so then my question
became
how many not sunny days or years might
we have over the course of 10 000 years
right if there was a lockheed or a
tambora yeah or worse yeah so we don't
get a synchronization event so that
became that it was interesting that we
had a property with these bristle cones
and we asked those scientists this
question say how many years over five
thousand or ten thousand um would we
have to deal with making the clock be
accurate for um but it's interesting how
this data kind of keeps coming back as
this very useful thing and strangely we
bought a property in eastern nevada that
has these trees on it but the the other
side of the data that they're
correlating is um is the ice core data
so i think that shows how much
um that's where they get the particulate
right the aerosols yeah yeah which is
both ash
i assume it's mostly ash and so like a
detail in all this is that
is that these volcanoes produce ash
which is not ash it's just powdered
aerosolized lava
but
so that's a kind of dusty stuff that's
typically in the lower atmosphere but
then the sulfates are are up high and
they can have
countervailing effects so an ash blanket
can make things warmer sulfates can make
things cooler and that's one reason why
the correlations aren't always super
obvious
and so if we use some of these
technologies to potentially
shade the planet there's still other
effects of things like the co2
precipitating into the oceans and it's
just kind of a stop gap absolutely yeah
anyone who studies this at all
will will will admit that right off the
bat that
um the real problem is the co2 and even
if the the
warming effects of co2 could be
counteracted
uh through some intervention like this
you'd still have
ocean acidification and other
nasty byproducts of of too much co2 in
the atmosphere
um
so um so the only way to to to think
about this is as like applying a
tourniquet
you know while the patient is
transported to the hospital
and that i mean there's also i mean
there's a lot of ways to do geo
engineering you you chose this one
because it was
interesting
it it's it's simple and the guy who's
doing it is a texas oil
billionaire he's he's backgrounds in the
oil and mining industry
and uh if you've ever you know
dealt with people like that it's a you
know simple is good
you know let's roll up our sleeves let's
let's build a thing
uh and and um
so to me it just seemed like
uh
the the kind of solution that would
appeal to that kind of person
and also it's just the most dead simple
way of doing this kind of intervention
and so
i thought that would make it seem a
little more immediate
as opposed to positing some hyper
advanced thing that hasn't been invented
yet
right
um and you've you've changed your
writing styles over the years you know
going back all the way to your first
there was the command line essay and
then uh with your baroque cycle or are
you have you found a thing that you're
now doing or you continue to do it
changing it for different books
uh it's it's always a little different
um i i think uh
um
there's kind of a
one way of writing things when it's a
kind of contemporary
action you know thriller type of book
like remd or
or uh or termination shock and then um
uh you know different styles to simply
dovetail with with different uh kinds of
books
i mean i had a lot of fun
sort of copying the
the the sort of uh
the 17th century english writing style
in the baroque cycle because it's
bombastic and they they capitalized
letters at random and
they italicize things uh
and um
uh and it's just kind of hilarious to
read
and then and also your methodologies
right you i think you started
handwriting back
at the birth cycle is that still yeah
something you're doing yeah i'm still
still doing that um
uh
there have been a couple books since
then where they that got started on um
uh on a word processor
and um and so i just kept doing them
that way but for the most part i do all
original composition with fountain pen
on paper so this whole book was written
yeah i i i realized uh
i realized before i uh uh just came on
stage here that i had forgotten to post
my picture of the
stack which is about
about that high for the manuscript for
this book
and i mean the other thing that you do
and we've crossed over a little bit
around uh
both uh
both your daughter and i build battle
bots and you've worked on it but you you
are a constant builder of physical
things um what what kind of physical
projects are you are you working on
these days well um
my kind of uh
thing-making uh energies for a while
were um
uh were being absorbed uh by some some
work that uh we were doing a magic leap
to make content for augmented reality
which
is not a physical building well it
turned into a physical building thing
project i have a way of doing that
but um
but that stopped a year and a half ago
and so uh during uh lockdown i started
just
killing time by
building stuff and um
you know i made some some robot parts uh
and um and then uh
uh
about a year ago i
acquired a vertical machining center
uh and um
and and the rusty oliver hazard factory
in seattle was kind enough to
clear some space for it so it's
so now i have a vertical machining
center and then a couple months ago i
got an engine lathe or antique not
antique but a sort of vintage
italian uh lathe um
and um
graziano sag 17.
and um
um the usual gateway drugs
yeah
exactly so
so we're kind of tooling up and and then
that draws people in you know who have
projects they want to build and work on
so
uh you know just within the last couple
weeks i've
connected up with someone uh a techie in
the uh
seattle area who
has suddenly
become interested in carbon capture
so
i
let him know that i can turn his
drawings into atoms uh
you know if it comes to that you're
going to start building some carbon
capture machines
um uh on a very small scale perhaps yeah
yeah um but you got to start somewhere
well and you mentioned magic leap and
i'm sure uh this is
a slightly painful subject at this point
but with the advent of meta and all that
and
where where you started with this but
you you have some some thoughts as to
the way this is coming back at you
well it's very weird uh
it's very weird but um the uh
i mean people have been um
sort of uh poking at the idea of the
metaverse since the book came out and
have come up with various
visions of what it could look like and
ways to implement it
and so
but nothing like
facebook
changing its name to meta and announcing
that they're now a metaverse company so
we're followed immediately by uh
microsoft and disney
two other companies you may have heard
of um saying that they too are metaverse
companies
epic is a metaverse because there's a
lot of metaverse companies out there
um
so uh
it uh it doesn't doesn't bring me
anything except a you know weird
annoying uh
you know contacts on on social media but
um
uh and and probably it probably sells a
few more copies of snow crash so that's
not all bad but um
[Applause]
i said uh i mean one of the other uh
thing that i work with your daughter and
uh your son-in-law on is the clock
project they've been engineers on the on
the project since since the beginning so
it's been really great
it's become a family business yeah and
working with them so it's been really
fun
um
that
i think and on that subject uh you
actually wrote and i mentioned it
earlier you you sent in one of the
earliest clock ideas when i i first met
you almost 25 years ago yeah and i
wonder if you could
talk about that a little bit because i
thought it was one of the more fun ideas
that we played around with and yeah
we're actually doing some version of it
for the vlog it was um
it was during the run-up to uh the turn
of the millennium and i think long now
wanted to to put the the clock was still
just kind of
just getting started and so
to observe the the
turning over of the odometer at 2000 the
idea was to to put up at least some
visions of what the clock might look
like and so
danny and others asked
a few people to just sort of draw up
their ideas of what it might look like
and i had been thinking
about
about kind of reading the newspaper
every day and um
you know getting this constant stream of
information um
and um
was it really uh was it really that
important to read it every day or
because at the end of the year they
always publish a year end roundup of the
news right and then at the end of the
decade they
they published the you know the the
decade roundup and in uh at that time
they were starting to prepare their end
of century and end of millennium you
know news roundup so you know the norman
conquest and you know
you know all these other things
and um
and so it just got me thinking like what
if you actually structured your life
around that so that
you would make a decision that you were
only going to
get an update of the news once a year
or
once every 10 years or whatever and so
that produced the idea of monastic
orders that would kind of take a vow to
that effect and they would live in a
set of
at the time i drew it as concentric
rings with walls
and and gates that would open under
clock power every year or every 10 years
or every hundred or thousand years
um
and when they were open you could pass
through the gate you could leave if you
wanted or you could go in deeper you
know and become an even more uh isolated
uh person
so that was the
that was what i sketched out and i think
it's probably still up on the long now
site somewhere
um and then that
became the basis of my novel anathem
with so with a lot of elaboration and
variation
well in in the novel they're not they're
no longer concentric you don't they're
they're kind of just
uh
arranged around the property
the concentric thing wasn't going to
work because everyone needs access to
the clock tower right
so
yeah
interesting intervention into a world
that has lots of multi thousand year
clocks yeah
do we have some
questions
thank you all right
all right
um
let's see all right from alec v we have
a could
vr ar metaverse be used to simulate the
problem and make it feel more real
um
i'm assuming you mean about uh climate
change and things like that
i think it could be a great display
mechanism to i mean you can't really get
a grip on what
one of these interventions might do
until you
perform a simulation um and we've got
pretty good software now for uh
for for running climate simulations uh
and um and and seeing how effects are
geographically distributed and and
that's that's kind of the basis of the
book because if you look at one of these
simulations you see
you might see a splotch somewhere in in
in india or africa or or america
where there would be a
severe drought
or or massive flooding
um and so that kind of spatial data is
really important uh in thinking about
these these problems and these
interventions and
and ar vr is a good way to display that
stuff
um unfortunately it would only work on
people who already believe in the
existence of human caused climate change
and
anyone else would would dismiss it out
of hand as you know communist propaganda
so i'm not sure it would help with that
part of the the problem
and uh peter asks um do you think it's
truly inevitable that we're going to
deploy some of this kind of solar geo
engineering
i wouldn't say anything's inevitable but
um
i think it's under discussed right now
in in our discourse around climate
change
because
it is sort of a taboo
idea
and um and
and and so i i think it it's okay to
bring it out into the open and talk
about it more um
because uh
sooner or later um
again if you read if you read the
opening chapter of kim stanley
robinson's ministry for the future
which is typically for him a
meticulously researched and carefully
drawn
account of one of these disasters
it doesn't take more than one or two of
those
to to get a government thinking about uh
some kind of intervention
um so i do think that um
it's gonna get talked about and maybe
gonna get done
in in in some parts of the world that
aren't quite so um
so meticulous about uh
self
censorship
every day i think it's it's very
interesting how that conversation around
geoengineering creates so much
um
controversy when fundamentally we are
geoengineering the planet and have been
right now for hundreds of years it's
it's kind of one of those things it's
also revive and restorers had this issue
of you know if we've been extincting
species right for thousands of years but
the moment you are purposeful in
bringing one back people get they start
using this phrase you know what kind of
consequences yeah those so we can't we
can't have those ferrets coming back
yeah
yeah
yeah no it is a an odd um
kind of
uh
habit of thought that that we've got
into and i know why it's the it's the
precautionary principle
and the precautionary principle is there
for good reasons you know we we screwed
a bunch of stuff up
um
but um
but yeah uh
one of the great things about charles
mann's
books 1491 1493 is the completely nuking
the the idea that
that there was a such a thing as
pristine nature
um you know we
even uh indigenous peoples um
all over the world uh were were
geoengineering their
uh their ecosystems and their climate
for tens of thousands of years
uh before the first uh settlers even
showed up
yeah so it seems to be fine to do
geoengineering haphazardly but yeah if
we do it with intention then
then we all shouldn't have to have a big
discussion about it
yeah
uh anna marie uh is asking
it's it sounds like you believe that in
100 years we will have successfully
sequestered enough carbon but she's
wondering i think why do you why do you
have so much hope is it just because we
have to because we have to
yeah and um
and i i think once it gets rolling and
we find processes that'll that'll work
that it'll um
it'll become a thing that people are
excited about and that people want to to
take part in
um
and you know we just it it's a thing
that has to be done
yeah i mean work i guess that we have a
question here about the fires here but i
think we've seen we are starting to do
some geoengineering by with the extreme
level of fires that we're having and i
think one of the more interesting pieces
of data that i saw was after 9 11 the 21
days that the planes didn't fly over the
united states
that um temperature actually rose
so there's because the contrails weren't
yeah so there's this interesting other
effect that can happen where
you can mask
the effects of global warming and
actually by taking some things out of
the air you can create a new problem
right yeah yeah so yeah
cool uh let's see um
we have shane asking uh what what what
are you reading these days and do you
read fiction or non-fiction for the most
part i mostly read um
uh non-fiction i mostly read read
history
books um so um
i i did
finally i i postponed
buying and re-reading the mr because i
knew it was out there
and i wanted to finish my book first um
so so that's definitely
on my my bedside table now and um
for you know as a guilty pleasure i read
the the fantasy novels of joe
abercrombie uh
he's got about nine of those things out
now and they're they're amazingly good
reads um
and then um
a bunch of a bunch of history the some
of the books that i mentioned um
the fate of rome uh
is a particularly amazing book uh this
basically looks at what happened to rome
through the lens of both climate change
and
pandemics
um and how those two interacted so
the the part i didn't read about the 536
uh
eruptions and the cold weather that
followed
uh is that that cold snap effectively
opened a channel by which
bubonic plague was able to escape from
its reservoir in central asian marmot
colonies and make it out to the
mediterranean and led to the justinian
plague which he
gives a spectacular description of i
mean
yersinia pestis man that is one
seriously bad
actor and now we don't you know we've
got antibiotics that can control it and
so we kind of underrate it
you know
but um it was almost 50 percent of the
known population of the world was still
yeah yeah and and
and in its when it really gets rolling
and and it just gets
transmitted through the air
you know people would would begin to
experience symptoms and be dead within
an hour or two
just unbelievable
uh bad stuff and
but it's it's bottled up in certain
areas un until the temperature uh
changes in such a way that enables uh
the vectors of it to escape right well
we uh we had uh jeffrey mano and uh and
nikola twilio they were talking about
their in their book about the history of
pandemics the thing i didn't know is
that passports were actually invented
during that time that they were they
were there to show that you were you
were not uh gonna transmit the disease
it's it's interesting ironic now that
people are really upset about passports
being used in this fashion right that's
actually what they're interested in why
they exist yes it's a pandemic yeah
yeah that's that's great so so that's a
great book to read that children of ash
and elm
totally knew history of the vikings is
another one that i
enjoyed very much
um
well
leona's asking if you could share more
about why you find the comancy species
preservation so important but i guess
also
without ruining the part of the book
about this oh well i mean i mean there's
there's a there's some some comanche
related content in in the book uh it's
not too much of a spoiler uh it happens
in in west texas
but um
the um
uh
the the place that i mentioned comanche
eagle dot org is is ostensibly a raptor
uh rescue center so like a lot of places
like that you go in and you'll see
eagles and hawks and so on that they've
been kept alive that were shot by a
hunter or something maybe they can't fly
but
they're they're being fed and kept
kept alive uh at this place and they can
make new
you know the the parts of them involved
in making new eagles still work uh
so um
so there's that but but these people
also have
are doing a great job of preserving uh
old photos and records and
and i'm going to use the word artifacts
uh
like uh weapons and and other uh items
um
uh that are um that that tell the the
story of that that people
which is a really interesting and
unusual group of of of people i i won't
try to go any
deeper than that but
uh
even among native american
tribes they've got a really unusual
story
and uh
adam is asking um what your favorite
type of carbon capture or storage
technology that you're seeing now way
you know um
the tough part is the scale
it has to work on so there's
there's some dialogue in the book where
the tr is saying that the amount of
carbon we have to remove from the
atmosphere if you just turn it into
carbon black and made a pile of it
would be the size of mount rainier
it would be about 30 cubic miles of
solid carbon
and so um i
remember looking at some an idea i
thought it was cool a few years ago and
you know like we were researching it and
talking about it and you know well maybe
we should try this and then
actually bothered to run the numbers and
and came to grips with the fact that um
it wasn't big enough i mean there's no
way
as as uh
recently a friend of mine dropped out of
jpl to start a carbon capture company
and his comment was we're going to need
a lot of fans
yeah you somehow you have to filter all
of the air in much of the atmosphere in
this device right right yeah scale is
pretty massive
so um
yeah because it's very dilute that's the
problem it's it's all over the world
there you can it's not concentrated
anywhere it's perfectly distributed all
over the
the world um and it's um it's not
present in high concentrations it's only
only 400 and some parts per million
so that's a that's a really hard problem
to solve so i i think my favorite
technology hasn't even been invented yet
but but people are working on it hard
and uh i think it's interesting one just
on the general nature of science fiction
here from anton is that you know people
often get more intrigued with the kind
of the cool new tech then really the way
that it's socioec and uh cultural
effects will play out and um you know i
think carbon capture is in in a way or
like geo engineering is kind of one of
these one of these things i mean
what's your take on how how you get
people to kind of see that side of
things and and
um
understand the cultural parts
specifically with with uh kind of uh
whether it's you know
the metaverse right
well i mean with with
social media stuff um
i mean it's uh
for me it's all about what
how are people making money
um
and
you know if if you're using an app
that's free
and constantly putting data into it
you should be asking yourself some
questions
and when you see that the people who who
make the app are becoming among the
wealthiest people and the companies
becoming one of the richest companies in
the world without charging you any money
so um
um so that that is uh
uh i think that probably goes goes to
the point that the question is making
about um you know think in terms of of
you know
what is actually going on behind the
curtain with some of these applications
and and first and foremost how are
people making money from it
uh there's an old saw
an old line about the
the
apps on the internet that
if you can't figure out what the product
is it's you
um
so
indeed yeah
the um
i think one of the questions here i
think with with this type of technology
like geoengineering is is how does this
become accepted um in the world i think
one of the interesting things obviously
that science fiction plays this role is
a way of playing something out like this
so that it can then be kind of more
accepted with another generation whether
or not it's it's our generation do you
see you've you've made some efforts in
trying to
make some large positive
uh
versions of science fiction rather than
just dystopic do you
where do you think
where do you think your role is and
other science fiction authors role in in
kind of playing out positive versus
dystopic futures
um well i i i think the important thing
is to to um to allow for some some
ambiguity uh and not try to go full
dystopian or or utopian
because readers seeing that will i think
sense that oh hang on a sec that's not
ever how it really is
um and so um
what i've tried to do in the case of
termination shock is to
you know to to just show this system
being built by this guy
as kind of the that's the opening that's
uh takes a while to get to it but that's
essentially already happened
at the beginning of the book
and then
rather than trying to portray that as a
dystopian or a utopian
behavior
show how different people respond to it
um and so in in this book there are some
people
uh
from low-lying uh areas that are
threatened by sea level rise who think
this is great
because this is going to save their
country
and there's other people who are afraid
that it's going to interrupt the monsoon
that their economy and their way of life
depends on and they are not happy about
it
and
so i think that's
a fairly realistic
depiction of um
of uh of what would happen if somebody
began to do this uh and i think um
the the best way to to to to cover it in
in a book is to um to show that
um and not
try to put put one's thumb on the scale
indeed
um well uh i think you pre-signed all
the books for this so we're sorry that
we can't do a signing just but for uh
covered reasons the passing of thousands
of books through hands is obviously not
the right move it seemed it seemed like
the most efficient conceivable scheme
to spread a respiratory virus yeah
exactly
if you didn't already buy a book there
are extra assigned ones out front and uh
i've really loved this book um can you
just say a little bit about what you
were working on next
uh well i've got a kind of a next book
project on the docket that um might i i
need to get going on but um
um
it'll be probably a couple of months
before i can get to it uh and you know
in the meantime um
you know uh i'm i'm puttering you know
i'm i'm gradually sliding into kind of
retired old weirdo
uh kind of
mode with this and um
and and making stuff that you know uh
is is
economically valueless but um
but at least i don't have to deal with
uh
you know raising money and
um
you know the the usual hassles of
working in a an organized company so
um so that takes various forms uh
uh and um
um it's hopefully keeping me out of
trouble and you're just at the beginning
of this book tour yet it's a start
you're just kidding yeah you're gonna
this is me and my peek in case
in case you're wondering yeah
yeah it's all downhill from here
um
nice well uh i'm gonna let stewart have
the closing question um since uh he's
he's been gracious enough to do the
sorting here um
and he's asking um is is climate change
helping humanity think longer term oh
well it seems like a great
way to
incentivize that
um
uh
you know um
it's uh
you you can't you can't think about it
unless you're thinking long term because
if you if you're not thinking long term
you're just talking about the weather
um
and so and we've all had the
conversation with the surly uncle at
thanksgiving dinner saying you know
you know it was cold last night i guess
that the pru disproves all of this
global warming nonsense um
you know uh
and so um
so we kind of have to it's you know i
suppose it's a
you know a kind of a potentially darwin
award moment for the whole species yeah
in
a certain way um hopefully we
hopefully we don't win the award
indeed well thank you so much yeah
thanks yeah pleasure
thanks
thank
y'all